MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABIES
PORCHES HEADFORD CABALLERO FOR
TENNESSEE VALLEY DOT THEY'RE
AWESOME. EGGMAN BLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTS BERG WEST SO HER
TADO JONES CAM AUGER WHERE'D
LEYVA THE MON THE GLIDER
MELINDA'S NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW
ABOUT. PAN PERSON TINA RALPH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER WHITE
HOUSE STEVE WEINER. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUEST ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RIGHTS WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR PAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED BY
THE PLEDGE DID NOT PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. WE PRAY. IN
THIS NEW YEAR WE PRAY. TO LIVE
DEEPLY WITH PURPOSE TO LIVE
FREELY WITH ATTACHMENT TO LIVE
WISELY WITH HUMILITY TO LIVE
JUSTLY WITH COMPASSION. TO LIVE
LOVINGLY WITH VITALITY TO LIVE
MINDFULLY WITH AWARENESS TO LIVE
GRATEFULLY THE GENEROSITY. TO
LIVE FULLY WITH ENTHUSIASM HELP
US- GOD TO HOLD THIS VISION. AND
TO DAILY RENEW OUR HEARTS
BECOMING EVER MORE ONE WITH YOU.
ONE ANOTHER AND ONE WITH OUR
TRUEST SELF A MAN. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A SALUTE TO
OUR COUNTRY I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
BECKER DOLLY MEN- TOWBOAT
FORTUNE TINO AND WILL
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON TO A REMOTELY
PARTICIPATING SENATORS. MEMBERS
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
MOVE A BILL. TO THE INACTIVE
FILE OR TAKE IT OFF THE INACTIVE
FILE. SEEING THE MICROPHONES UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JANUARY THIRD
THROUGH SIX TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLARK. INTRODUCTION
AND FIRST READING OF BILLS MADAM
SECRETARY EXCUSE ME SENATOR
GLAZER. UNDER MOTION WAS
RESOLUTION YES PRESIDENT KIND OF
FAST THEY'RE GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY I WANT TO REMOVE TWO
ITEMS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. I
AM TWENTY SEVEN S. B. SEVEN
EIGHT FIVE AND ITEM THIRTY SIX
SCA FIVE I THINK I THINK IT'S AN
ORGANIZER THE DESK WILL NOTE.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING
NONE INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY NINE AND SENATE BILL
EIGHT FORTY THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILLS. FOR FORTY FOUR
FOUR FIFTY THIRTY FOUR FORTY
NINE. FIFTY THREE SIX FIFTY SIX
FIVE FORTY TWO AND SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY FOUR YOU MIGHT FORTY
THREE THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
WILL NOW MOVE TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEMS THIRTY AND
THIRTY ONE WILL START WITH
FALLON THIRTY SENATOR LAYERED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. FINAL
ITEM THIRTY IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOUG HENDRICKSON TO THE STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION HE IS THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
WASSERMAN SPORTS AGENCY HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATERULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY SEVENTH ON A
FOUR ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE AND SEEING THEM
FROM OUR REPORT LOOKED REMOTELY
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS I
BAIT. FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE A
CORTEZ THREE I DON. FIVE TORONTO
FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO I- TANTO I JONES NO
CAMEL OWNER. I LAYERED HI LABOUR
I THE MON I MEAN WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO NEWMAN. I NIELSEN.
PAN I FOR ROCK. FIVE RUBIO I
SCANNER. I STERN HI NUMBER FIVE
BY CAL SKI I WINNER HI THIS CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. BASED FOR
JUST NOW HI BYRON ROVE. NIELSEN. HI BY TWENTY SEVEN NOES THREE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
PHYLUM THIRTY ONE ST EARLIER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE
I'M THIRTY ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
APPOINTMENTS OF VIVIAN PEREZ TO
THE COLORADO RIVER BASIN
REGIONAL BOARD AS ROMA STUFF OF
THE TO THE LA HUTTON BOARD DR
MICHAEL MENDEZ AND HAMID NOT
HIDE TO THE LOS ANGELES REGIONAL
BOARD THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST TWENTY FIFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I WANTED TO WEIGH IN ON
BEHALF OF DAVID THE HIGH HAD ME
DAVID DIED WITH A FRIEND OF MINE
FOR MANY YEARS AND I WATCHED HIM
WHEN HE WAS THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER IN
LOS ANGELES TOGETHER WITH MANY
OTHER ACTIVITIES IN THIS IN THE
FIELD AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
APPOINTMENT THE SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY. OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING ON
THE FLOOR OR REMOTELY THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA FIVE ACTIONS
HI BABY. FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
KAVEH ADAM QUARTET THE FIVE DOT. HI YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN I
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS I GROSS.
HERTZBERG HI WESTERN I HER TADO
. I JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED
HI LABOUR FIVE THE MON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
PAM HI RALPH HI RUBIO I CAN- HI
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER HI. THIS CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. BASED PORGES. HAVE I
EVER. GROVE JONES. NIELSEN. FIVE
THREE SEVEN KNOWS ONCE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX OH TWO BY
SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT RELATING
TO CONSERVATORSHIP. SIMILAR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB SIX
OH TWO REQUIRE PROBATE
CONSERVATORSHIP TO SUBMIT A
COMPREHENSIVE CARE PLAN FOR THE
CARE OF CONSERVATIVES IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF THEIR STATES-
THERE BEEN NO NO VOTES OR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I WOULD
pCENTER LAYERED MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I BAIT.
PORCHES I BRADFORD HI BY ADAM OR
TESTING I DON ARE YOU THERE
AWESOME. I EGGMAN I LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I WROTE. I HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN. HI HER TADO
HI JOHN I CAN LONGER HI LAYERED
I LABOR I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
PAM HI RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER
. I STERN HI I'M BERG I LIKE HOW
SKI FIVE WINNER FIVE. PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS. FAITH
HAVE I EVER NIELSEN. FIVE THIRTY
ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE ALSO SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
LAYERED AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER
LAYERED- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH. AN OFFICE
OF SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
OMBUDSPERSON THERE'S BEEN ISSUES
WITH THE SELF THE PART
TERMINATION PLANS BEING DONE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES IN THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MICHAEL. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING HEARING DOWN
ON THE FLOOR SEEING AND HEARING
THEN REMOTELY BEEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ADKINS. I FACE
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I KERR BIO
PROTECTING HI TODD I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER AIKENS OLIVE
HIGH GROWTH. I HEARD SPURRED HI
WITH SOME. I HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON I
LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN.
PAM HI RALPH I REVERE I SCANNER
. I STERN HI I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT
I RECOUNT SKI I WINNER I. PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS. BAIT
COME BY OTHER. NIELSEN I THIRTY
ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT OUR LAST MAJOR FOR THE
DAYS SENATOR WIENER ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU VERY. THANK
YOU HELLO THERE I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOT A PRESIDENT- ALEX-
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE
THOSE TWO THINGS TO SUPPORT OUR
HOSPITALITY- AND THEY LIGHT
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE SUFFERED SO
BADLY DURING THE PANDEMIC OFFERS
TO CREATE A NEW LIVE MUSIC- AND
ENTERTAINMENT I'LL HOLD LICENSE
RIGHT NOW LIVE MUSIC VENUES HAVE
A CHOICE OF EITHER GETTING A BAR
LIQUOR LICENSE WHICH MEANS THAT
NO ONE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE CAN ENTER FOR A RESTAURANT
LIQUOR LICENSE WHICH MEANS THEY
HAVE TO PUT IN A FULL RESTAURANT
CALIBER KITCHEN WHICH IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE. EVEN IF
THEY'RE REALLY NOT- FOCUSED ON
FOOD SERVICE SERVICE BILL WILL
CREATE A NEW A LICENSE SPECIFIC
TO LIVE MUSIC VENUES THESE
VENUES HAVE BEEN DECIMATED BY
THE PANDEMIC THEY WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY CLOSE FOR MANY
MANY MANY MONTHS I COULDN'T OPEN
AT ALL- AND- THIS IS A GOOD STEP
FOR THIS HONOR FOR AN ELEMENT OF
MY LIFE IN CALIFORNIA THE SECOND. THING THE BILL DOES IS- INSANE
. WHAT CAN DO WHEN- A OPEN
CONTAINERS OWN CITIES CAN
CURRENTLY CREATING OPEN
CONTAINER ZONE FOR EXAMPLE
DURING A STREET FESTIVAL- OR
OTHER PUBLIC EVENTS- WHERE
ALCOHOL CAN BE SOLD. HOWEVER
ALCOHOL CAN ONLY BE SOLD BY A
VENDOR THAT COMES IN THE OPENING
TENDERS ON FROM OUTSIDE. THE
BRICK AND MORTAR RESTAURANTS AND
BARS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
PHYSICALLY AND I ZONE OR
PROHIBITED FROM SELLING. AND
STREET FAIR OR FESTIVAL- SERVICE
LEGISLATION WILL AUTHORIZE
CITIES- WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
CREATE AN OPEN CONTAINER ZONE TO
ALLOW OTHER EXISTING BRICK AND
MORTAR BARS AND RESTAURANTS TO
PARTICIPATE- AND- FAIR OR
FESTIVAL. I RESPECT WESTERN
IDAHO. THANK YOU SENATOR WE-
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I'M QUESTIONED THE AUTHOR. I
SAID WHEN WE TAKE A QUESTION IF
YOU WILL PLEASE PROCEED I
APPRECIATE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BUT I DO HAVE ONE A
QUICK QUESTION WYNN- THE
PANDEMIC WAS IN FULL FORCE IN
TWENTY TWENTY IN RESTAURANTS AND
BARS WERE CLOSED DOWN. OF BARS
AND RESTAURANTS THAT HAD A
CABARET LICENSE WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO OPERATE IS THIS AN ADDITIONAL
LICENSE TO THE CABARET LICENSE
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE LIVE MUSIC
OR IS THIS WELL THE CO INSIDER
WORK TOGETHER I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF RESTAURANTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE REQUIRED TO GET AN
ADDITIONAL LICENSE. THAT'S MY
QUESTION. THROUGH THE THIRTEENTH
PLEASE PROCEED YESTHIS IS A
NEW- SEPARATE LICENSE OVER
RESTAURANT HAS A RESTAURANT
LYSONS- THAN A- CAN ALREADY
SERVE ALCOHOL- UNDER LOCAL LAWS
THEY MAY SOMETIMES. TO HAVE LIVE
MUSIC AS A RESTAURANT OR BAR.
YOU NEED TO GET A SEPARATE LOCAL
LAND USE PERMIT TO DO THAT. AND
THIS ONE AND PETER ABILITY TO DO
THAT BUT THEY ALREADY HAVE. AN
ALCOHOL LICENSE- THE CHALLENGE
OF THE LIVE MUSIC VENUES FACES.
THERE'S NO LIQUOR LICENSE THAT
REALLY APPLIES TO THEM SO THEY
HAVE TO PRETEND TO BE A BAR. OR
PRETEND TO BE A RESTAURANT- EACH
OF WHICH BRINGS SORT OF SOME
CHALLENGES FOR THEM BOTH OF THEM
FOR THEIR BUSINESS MODEL. SO
THIS IS INTENDED TO CREATE. A
LIQUOR LICENSE SPECIFIC. TO
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C.
AND HEARING ON ON THE FLOOR. OR
REMOTELY CENTER WINTER YOU MAY
CLOSE. REQUEST FOR AN ITEM THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE I EVER CORTELLI
I THOUGHT FIVE TORONTO HI A
COMMON FIVE GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS
HI GROSS. I HEARD SPURRED BY
WESTERN. I HER TADO I JONES I
CAN'T MARKER. I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MON FIVE MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN
. HI PAM HI RALPH I REVIEW FIVE
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG ALL
RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI. I WINNER I. I WAS THIRTY TWO DOES ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS REMOVING
AREN'T MANY ANNOUNCEMENTS
SENATOR HUESO. FEDERATED YOU ONE
ELSE ABOUT YOUR COMMITTEE.
IN A
WAY SO YES THANK YOU OF OUR
PRESENT SENATORS- ENERGY
UTILITIES AND TELECOM
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT
OF SENATE SO WE'LL SEE YOU THERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE AND I
THINK YOU'LL BE MEETING- RIGHT
HERE IN THE OKAY HERE IN THE YES
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
WE ARE RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A GERMAN IN
MEMORIES. I'M GOING TO START
WITH SENATOR WIENER IF YOU ARE
READY. TO PROCEED. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ARE CALLING SO I
ASK THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED
TODAY IN MEMORY OF CHARLIE
STARBUCK- THIS IS SO SAD FOR SO
MANY OF US WHEN WE LEARNED OF
CHARLIE'S. PASSING AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FOUR HE WAS- VOLUNTEER-
TO. SPENT MANY MANY MANY YEARS
TRYING TO EXPAND SERVANTS
CISCO'S URBAN FOREST- CHARLIE
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IN NEW YORK- HE ENLISTED
IN THE AIR FORCE AND SERVED AS A
STAFF SERGEANT AND THE TACTICAL
AIR COMMAND. AFTER LEAVING THE
SERVICE YOU'RE ROLLED AND ROLLED
IT PAST UNIVERSITY. PASTORS A
MASTER'S DEGREES IN ACCOUNTING.
AFTER A STINT AT ARTHUR ANDERSEN
HE GOT A LAW DEGREE TO HIS LAST
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
PITTSBURGH NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THREE YEARS LATER. HE WAS IN
PRACTICE AS A DEFENSE LAWYER
WHEN YOU DECIDE TO MOVE. TO THE
GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE HIS SISTER AND WAS LIVING.
CHARLIE WITH A SOLO PRACTITIONER
IN TAX LAW- WHICH ALSO TAUGHT AT
CITY COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO-
BUT HIS LIFE'S WORK WAS TRULY AS
A VOLUNTEER- WITH SAN
FRANCISCO'S FRIENDS OF THE URBAN
FORESTS- HE ALSO SERVED A TERM
ON THE PLANNING COMMISSION IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. UNDER
MAYOR GEORGE MOSCONI FORMER.
MEMBER AND LEADER AND THIS BODY.
ON SO OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS- CHARLIE PROBABLY SPEND
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND DAYS- AND
TEN THOUSAND HOURS- VOLUNTEERING
AND PLANTING MORE THAN EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED- TREES- FRIENDLY
OVER FOREST IS AN AMAZING
ORGANIZATION IN SAN FRANCISCO.
FOR MORE THAN FORTY YEARS HAS
SPEARHEADED THE PLANTING OF MORE
STREET TREES. IN OUR CITY AND
MENTORING FOR THOSE TREES. I
WOULDN'T BE DOING VOLUNTEER
NEIGHBORHOOD MOBILIZATIONS I'VE
ATTENDED MANY OF- THE REALLY
INSPIRING. TO THE NEIGHBORS
COMING TOGETHER. TO PLANT MORE
TREES WITH ALL OF THE HEALTH AND
QUALITY OF LIFE BENEFITS ABOUT
BRINGS. ON OVER THE MANY YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN ATTENDING FRIENDS
OF THE URBAN FOREST NEIGHBORHOOD
TREE PLANTINGS. I DON'T THINK
I'VE EVER ATTENDED ONE WORD
CHARLIE WASN'T THERE. WITH HIS
SIGNATURE GREEN BERET- AND HIS
SAYS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
POSITIVE. ENTHUSIASM HE IN SO
MANY WAYS SYMBOLIZE FRIENDS OF
URBAN FOREST AND TREE PLANTING
ACTIVISM IN THE CITY. OF SAN
FRANCISCO- HE SURVIVE BY HIS
BROTHER JOHN AND SISTER AND- I
IS ALSO SURVIVED BY A NIECES AND
NEPHEW- THEY'VE ALL HAD STREET
TREES IN SAN FRANCISCO PLANTED
BY THEIR UNCLE. AS BIRTHDAY
GIFTS PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY-
INTERNING IN OUR GREAT SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE MEMORY OF OUR
GREAT SAN FRANCISCAN. CHARLIE
STARBUCKS. I THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
STATE SENATE. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR WAY SO ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR. IN A WAY SO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO A TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
A BELOVED. COMMUNITY LEADER IN
ORGANIZER- WHO HE WHO PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY FIFTH-
PEACEFULLY AT HIS HOME IN THE
SHERMAN HEIGHTS COMMUNITY THE
FOR THE SENATE DISTRICT. CLOSE
DONALD TOMASA GOMES WAS BORN ON
DECEMBER TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO AND LOST I DID NOT
LIST ET RACHEL MEXICO AND MOVED
TO THE UNITED STATES IN NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE AS PART OF THE BREAST
CENTER PROGRAM. AND WORKED IN
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES CONTRIBUTING TO
THE POST WAR. WORLD WAR TWO
EFFORTS HE MOVED TO ALASKA WHERE
HE WORKED AS A LABORER IN THE
RAILROAD INDUSTRY AND ALSO
WORKED AS A COOK. ARGUABLY ONE
OF THE STERNEST PROUDEST MOMENTS
WAS TAKING PART IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE ICONIC SAN
DIEGO CONVENTION CENTER. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX MR GOMES
SETTLED IN THE SHERMAN HEIGHTS
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE HE LIVED FOR
LUKE NEARLY FIVE DECADES AS A
PROUD HOMEOWNER. HE BECAME AN
IMPORTANT COMMUNITY LEADER WHEN
THE COMMUNITY NEEDED HIM THE
MOST. HIS FIRST EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE SHERMAN HEIGHTS
COMMUNITY- REGARDED WORKING WITH
THE CITY GOVERNMENT AND
CHAMPIONING EFFORTS AT IMPROVING
STREET CLEANING PLACING STOP
SIGNS IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
CREATING A NEIGHBORHOOD OF
POLICING. AND A NEIGHBORHOOD
WATCH PROGRAM ALSO IN CREATING A
HISTORIC DISTRICT THE WORK WHICH
IS WHAT CONTRIBUTED TO HELP
MAKING WHAT SHERMAN HEIGHTS IS
NOW A HISTORIC DISTRICT. IS
ORGANIZED HE IS ORGANIZING
EFFORTS CONTINUED IN THE
EIGHTIES A MESS ESCALATING
VIOLENCE AND DRUG DISH IT
DICTION WHERE HE DEMANDED-
SOCIAL CHANGE WORK WITH. THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND SAN DIEGO
AS I MENTIONED TO CREATE A
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH AND IN
RESPONSE PROGRAM THAT HELPED
CLEAN UP. A LOT OF PROPERTIES
THAT WERE HOW- WORK WERE BEING
USED FOR DRUG DEALING IN ILLICIT
ACTIVITIES. HE SPEARHEADED
COMBAT IN THE DRUG EPIDEMIC THAT
DEVASTATED THE COMMUNITY WHILE
ENSURING THAT ILLICIT DRUG USES
CELLS AROUND SHERMAN ELEMENTARY
CAME TO AN END. HE WAS OF A
PERSON OF STYLE OF A OF ELEGANCE
. HE LIVE LIFE COURAGEOUSLY
INTENTIONALLY BAND A CHANGE IN-
MENTALITIES AND GETTING SO YOU
KNOW- TRACKING PEOPLE TO JOIN
HIS BECAUSE- BOB YOU KNOW I HAVE
TO SAY THAT. IN MY LIFE MY OWN
PERSONAL LIFE DURBAN I'VE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE. OF
CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT WERE
THOUGHTFUL AND PASSIONATE TO
SERVE AS ROLE MODELS FOR ME IN
IN THE INSPIRING ME TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AND- STANDARD GOMES WAS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE HE'S A
PERSON THAT NOT ONLY INSPIRED ME
TO PUBLIC SERVICE BUT MANY OTHER
PEOPLE. AS WELL. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE FOR KAELIN IS TWO
CHILDREN FRANKEN MAHDI SELA. HE
PROVIDE THE BUILDING BLOCKS. AND
THE SELF DETERMINATION TO THE
RESIDENTS OF A COMMUNITY THAT
NEEDED LEADERSHIP NEEDED.
DIRECTION AND NEEDED TO BE
EMPOWERED AND HIS LEGACY OF
SERVICE CAN BE SEEN IN EVERY
SINGLE PART. OF THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD AND WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO HIM AND IT'S A VERY
SAD TIME FOR US IN SAN DIEGO AND
IN THE SHERMAN HEIGHTS
COMMUNITY. WE WILL MISS THE
STUNNER GOMES VERY VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER WAY SO PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
RECOGNIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF FORMER KING
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
ANTHONY BARBA. FORMER SUPERVISOR
BARBARA PASSED AWAY NOVEMBER AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY SIX HE WAS
BORN IN HANFORD CALIFORNIA ON
JUNE THIRTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE TO PARENTS VICTORIA BODIES
AT TWENTY BARBARA. HE ATTENDED
THE COLLEGE OF THE SEQUOIAS AND
LATER ENTERED THE US ARMY. AFTER
LEAVING THE ARMY HE JOINED THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. WHEN
HE STARTED HIS CAREER WORKING IN
BALDWIN PARK BUT AFTER ABOUT TEN
MONTHS HE WAS ABLE TO TRANSFER
BACK TO HANFORD. AT THE TIME HE
WAS UNOFFICIALLY TOLD HE WAS THE
FIRST LATINO OFFICER ASSIGNED TO
THE HANFORD AREA AND HE REMAINED
IN HAND FOR THE REMAINDER OF
HIS. CAREER WHICH WAS TWENTY SIX
YEARS. IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
HE RAN FOR KINGS COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. I WAS ELECTED
BECOMING THE FIRST LATINO
SUPERVISOR TO BE ELECTED TO THE
BOARD. WHILE IN OFFICE HE HAD AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY AND WAS A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SENIORS AND
DISABLED YOUTH. MR BARBOUR
SURVIVED BY A SPELL. BY HIS
SPOUSE ALL FIJIAN BARBARA HIS
SON AND DAUGHTER IN LAW RONALD
ANTHONY AND CHRISTINE BARBER HIS
DAUGHTER. CHERYL ANN SILVA AND
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE JOIN
ME TODAY IN A TURNING IN THE
MEMORY OF ANTHONY BARBA AND
PAMPERED. THANK YOU CENTER HER
TADO PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE WILL BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. MEMBERS JUST A
LITTLE ADDENDUM TO SENATOR
HUESOS- ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT
COMMITTEE IT WILL ACTUALLY BEGIN
TWENTY MINUTES AFTER WE FINISH
HERE SO THE CHAMBER CAN BE
PROPERLY CLEANED. SO ENERGY WILL
MEET TWENTY MINUTES AFTER WE
TURN HERE. MEMBERS IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A LONG WEEK. OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THIS FRIDAY JANUARY
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT
NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE'LL RECONVENE FRIDAY MORNING
AT NINE AM. HAVE A GREAT REST
TODAY MEMBERS.